atrial fibrillation is a type of
arrhythmia which involves an abnormality
in the rhythm or force of
the heartbeat if you have
atrial fibrillation the
upper chambers of the heart will contract in
a rapid and disorderly way
causing an
uncoordinated heartbeat and  irregular the heart is
a muscular organ made up of
four chambers the left and
right atria and the left and right ventricles
during a normal heartbeat the
chambers of your heart contract and
relax in a rhythmic pattern to
provide a constant flow of blood
throughout your body
the right atrium receives blood from the
body
and the right ventricle pumps it to
the lungs which carry oxygen and
remove carbon dioxide from the
blood
at the same time the left atrium
receives blood from the lungs
and the left ventricle  pumps it to
deliver oxygen and nutrients to
body tissues
every lat  The flow of the heart begins in the
natural pacemaker of the heart called
the sinus node or s/a node located in
the wall of the right atrium,
an electrical signal is started here, then it
spreads through both atria
causing them to contract and eject
blood into  the
ventricles as the atria relax the
signal travels through the
atrioventricular node or
ave node to the ventricular walls
causing the
ventricles to contract they relax achieving a
full beat
immediately the s/a node generates a
new electrical impulse repeating the
pattern
in atrial fibrillation
electrical signals originate from
unusual places in the atria and near
the pulmonary veins
these abnormal signals travel
through the atria randomly causing
the atria to contract in a
rapid and disorderly manner
the signals bombard the ave node
cause the ventricles to
contract rapidly even  in an
even faster rhythm the
ventricular contractions cannot keep
pace with the rapid atrial contractions this
is what causes an
uncoordinated heartbeat after
these
irregular contractions the chambers may not empty
completely when blood pools in
the  clots could form in the atria
a clot can break free from the
heart and travel through your neck
to your brain
causing a stroke
the buildup of blood in the
ventricles prevents oxygen and
nutrients from reaching body tissues
if your heart is constantly
unable to  pump enough blood
to meet your
body's needs then you may
develop heart failure
your doctor may treat your atrial
fibrillation with
antiarrhythmic drugs antiarrhythmic drugs
control the
electrical signals sent to your atria
that help your heart beat at a normal rate
gular after treatment it is
possible that your heart is still beating very
fast in this case your doctor may
give you beta-blocker medicines
so that your heart rate
slows down to normal
and your doctor may recommend
procedures that restore the
normal rhythm and rate of your heart such
as
cardioversion ablation
or pacing
in electrical cardioversion your doctor will
deliver a shock to your heart
to start a normal heart rhythm
during ablation
the surgeon will use
radiofrequency energy to destroy the
heart tissue that is generating the
abnormal electrical signals
in the  pacemaker placement the
surgeon will implant a small
device under the skin near
your heart to regulate your heart rhythm